hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds and firstly i hope you had an
amazing christmas and i think you know
what in between
christmas and new year is a really
really good time to start studying and
learning about property preparing your
business plan for 2022 so what i decided
to do
during this time is help my subscribers
on youtube to get their business plan in
place to answer their questions and help
them learn more about property
investment through youtube so that in
2022
bang you can start the year knowing
exactly what it is that you're doing so
i today i've decided i'm going to be
answering any questions that you've got
if you're a subscriber go ahead and ask
me a question in the comments and i will
do my very best to answer you and help
you in your property journey so you can
prepare for 2022 which is just a few
days away so i'm going to start
answering questions now that have been
commented uh last week but if you've got
questions now comment below and i'll do
my very very best to help you if you are
not subscribed already subscribe hit the
like button and start commenting below
with your questions and how i can help
so um zaheed ahmed thank you for being a
subscriber my brother i appreciate you
he says
um
he says my question is about buying a
property
for 30 000 pounds
that sounds very cheap can i get a
mortgage for 30 000 pounds or do i have
to pay cash can i refinance after
purchase i'll wait for your answer all
right so if you're buying a house for 30
000 pounds
my understanding because the rules do
change and lenders change their
requirements but you cannot get a
mortgage on a house as cheap as 30 000
pounds unfortunately the very cheapest
that you can buy a house and even think
about getting a mortgage is 40 000
pounds
so
if you're buying the house for 30 000
pounds
it could work if you're buying it you'd
have to buy cash or get a bridging loan
then it's no problem but even bridging
companies i don't think
you'd be probably better off just
getting a loan from a bank or a friend
or a credit card because it's such a
cheap house you might be getting a hard
loan
however i would only recommend doing
that if
you can increase the value of the
property by maybe getting a new kitchen
or fixing it and pushing the value to
above 40 000 pounds which means that you
buy cash for 30 you spend five pushing
the value up and then let's say the new
value is 45 you could then refinance it
pull out all your money and then boom
however
i don't know what property you're
talking about neither do i know your
situation so before you do that always
make sure you speak to a mortgage broker
to make sure that you can refinance it
at the end before you take a loan out to
buy cash and also of course you need to
make sure the property is a good
property it's in a decent area
you're not buying it for 30 grand um and
then it turns out that there's a mine
shaft under it so you know do you do
diligence do you research is there's
anything else i can help you with
let me know i got you all right next
question
does your class
applicable in australia
indonesia singapore and malaysia because
four of this country have different
prices on property and rent the good
news is yes my
teachings that i'm going to be sharing
just generally on the youtube channel
apply pretty much all over the world
because property investment boils down
to
putting down money investing money and
then seeing your return so if you're
buying a property in malaysia or
singapore or australia or in the uk then
you're going to want to be able to the
the strategies
are the same so you put put down a
deposit you rent it out you see a good
return on investment knowing how to work
out the return on investment your due
diligence point tenants into properties
i mean it's pretty pretty uh
you know international stuff in terms of
things like rent to rent and
biorefurbish refinance these are also
strategies that work all over the world
of course
you need to make sure before you do a
strategy that it works in your area but
even in the uk the rules are different
in scotland and in wales and in ireland
and in england even in england the rules
in london are different to the rules in
birmingham so you need to make sure that
you look at your
you know you you're clued up on your
local area knowledge but the strategy is
yes they are pretty much global
strategies congratulations i'm looking
forward to seeing you dominate asia with
your property investing skills stuart
leo says
any how
you think that
doing real estate in scotland is a good
idea
anyhow i think um okay scotland i love
scotland i think real estate in scotland
is a good idea
i actually prefer the way that the scots
buy properties because when you buy a
property in scotland number one
you can't sell a house without having a
home
buyers report done so you have a survey
on the house before you can sell it
which means that anyone that's offering
on a house before they offer they've got
a report on the house they can see they
know exactly what they're buying um if
you put an offer on a house and it's
accepted you have to go ahead and buy
the house so you can't mess around
there's no jumping so i really like the
rules in scotland however personally i
haven't got a portfolio in scotland my
properties are all in england and also
i've got a small portfolio also in wales
but yes i think scotland's great and the
returns in scotland are great and i've
got many scottish students that are
investing heavily into scotland
another question on scotland as well
someone says here um
[Music]
i live in aberdeen help me out can you
give me more info on doing all that you
teach in aberdeen scotland does it work
up here thanks in advance um absolutely
i mean i've got again i've got a guy
called a friend called simon who i've
trained and mentored and he
about three years ago came on the
property investors crash course he
started packaging deals
and selling them
and he was a deal sourcer he did that in
scotland he's now doing that he's making
about 20 grand
a month from packaging and selling deals
he's just bought a property or he's in
the pro supplier property in aberdeen
which is a huge huge development project
which he's funding with zero of his own
money and that's in aberdeen so you know
there's definitely money to be made in
aberdeen um i think it's really good if
you can if you can if you if you live
somewhere you know the area really well
if you know the area really well and
then you learn the strategies that i
teach you can apply those two things
together you can really really smash it
in your hometown so good luck in
aberdeen all right just a couple more
questions zach woodbury if you're
starting a game with 15 grand and you
had all your knowledge what would you do
rent to rent
control houses instead of buying houses
you can make a lot more cash flow do you
offer any courses in ireland um
irish folks come and see me all the time
i went to ireland on a financial freedom
challenge i dominated ireland so um
yeah man we can hook up we can do stuff
congratulations
where can i get in touch with
experienced deal sources looking for brr
properties i would probably do your
first one yourself because if you're
trying to pay someone to find you a deal
but you don't know what to do yourself
they'll pull the wall over your eyes
is it a good investment to buy a 75 000
pound house near a university that is a
two bed bringing in 1200 pounds a month
sounds good to me 75 grand house
bringing in 12 in japan a month rent
sounds awesome of course i can't advise
you buy the house because i don't know
anything about it or where it is but
those figures that you've told me sound
amazing
um simon king i've got 210 000 pounds in
equity in a 250 000 house
what's the way forward sell or refinance
all right um
depends if you refinance it you need to
look at what are your new interest
payments going to be
compared to the rent and are you going
to be cash flowing positive if you are
we finance it the money that you pull
out is tax-free because they can't tax
you on debt
if you refinance it and the rent won't
cover the mortgage properly then just
sell that house take the whole lot
and reinvest it into property that's
generally what i would say all right uh
we've got christopher hobart
please can i ask how do i find people to
lend me money so that i could buy one
and then do it up i would say rather
than trying to find someone to lend you
money if you start finding the deals the
money will come so get really good at
finding the deals the money will come
last question are mendola
please explain bridging loans would you
please make an in-depth video on
bridging loans pretty please look
bridging loans is a tool
bridging is very simply a loan
that you can use to buy a house
but it's very expensive
and it will bridge the gap between
buying a house and getting a mortgage
there's some houses that are
unmortgageable because they're in bad
condition they're inhabitable there's no
hot water maybe the seller just wants a
really quick buy and says cash buyers
only so you're going to buy houses at a
discount you're going to buy them cheap
you're going to buy them cash
and you're going to use a bridging loan
to buy them
buy them cheap do them up and then
you're going to then
refinance on a regular buy to let
mortgage at the higher value
and then that new mortgage is going to
pay off the bridging loan leaving you
with hopefully if you've done it right a
free house bridging finance is not a
strategy in and of itself it is a tool
so i hope that helps
guys hope you had a lovely christmas
comment your questions below and let's
make 2022 an incredible year god bless